okay so i grew up in southgate um
i come from a middle class family
functioning alcoholic grandparents
a teenage mother
my mother became lapd when i was four
and at the same time my dad went to
prison and became an aryan brother
so um
i've always been um
i have never felt like i was good enough
or
or loved
and um
i always had a you know a rebellious
streak in me
um growing up was great you know
my grandparents had a sailboat we did
family things
no complaints
my mom moved me away to oregon
and i was molested by her husband
at 10 i 10 years old i
testified in front of a grand jury in
washington
and um
that just made me completely uh
sexually active sexually open and um
by 12 years old i had eight partners
and i was a runaway i just started
running away there was no reason why um
i went to mclaren hall i ran into some
people
and i went from
city of southgate to south central
and
i got involved with
a whole different crowd nobody went to
school i did spray paint um
i ended up getting pregnant i had my
first child at 15.
um
and i tried to get back normal but i was
just so intrigued by the lifestyle it
was just the lifestyle it was being out
with no responsibility
and i was like a diamond in the rough i
loved it i love the streets
um
i got put onto a gang at 16
and then by the time i was 18 i started
smoking crack cocaine off with a pipe
and i was shunned from the hispanics
because i was smoking with blacks
and um
at 18 i got 20 000 from my college fund
i smoked it up in three and a half weeks
i was doing cartwheels on central
boulevard
in my bra with a train of smokers behind
me
i was
had no idea what i was doing i was just
just living life at the moment and um
i'll never forget the last day i had it
uh the last day my last dollar
i was put out in the street and i
couldn't get no one to buy me a jumbo
jack
and that was the first time i was
introduced to um prostitution
i thought it was my boyfriend he was
really what he would call a gorilla pimp
you know he put me out on central
boulevard didn't even tell me what to
charge
and
he put me in the car with the with the
trick
i asked the trick what to charge
he said 25
no condom the [ __ ] and suck
wow
okay i needed some rocks smoking crack
um so that went on for a little while
you know i got i got beat up
pretty bad
by that guy that i thought loved me and
then um
you know i um i endured a lot of
i saw a lot of things out there that i
wasn't i didn't come from i didn't come
from ever being beat or um
you know watching you know just the
lifestyle out there became very
dangerous um
so i kind of had to like
adapt
i caught my first case
at 19 um
i was
prostituting selling drugs at the same
time and
gram of cocaine sent me to prison for
the first time for 16 months
and i've been in and out of prison ever
since
i've done uh about 15 years of my adult
life
in prison
all drug related um
i only commit crimes when i'm on
drugs
[Music]
um so let's see back to that i have
three children
and um
my uh one of my children is a product of
rape
i was raped by two guys out here they
said they were raping me because uh
i walked by them like i was too good
they were kids they were 16 i was about
24.
definitely used to walk by him wasn't my
thing
um
you know um
i thought i was always doing the best
thing i could but the the truth was i
was addicted to the lifestyle for so
long
um
it didn't matter what happened to me out
there
i've been
stomped out i've been raped three times
i have a product or a baby for a product
of a rape
i've witnessed a homicide i've been all
involved in
numerous uh
scenarios that
i don't even know i made it out alive
but um
you know
it just made me who i am today
made me stronger it made me uh a
survivor
it made me get it you know um
i don't judge anybody
but along the way i lost uh i lost a lot
of things
i lost uh my family doesn't talk to me
at all
um i still struggle with addiction
um
you know i'm a three striker i'm looking
at time
and
um know i'm still very much addicted to
the lifestyle
it doesn't matter how dangerous it is
out here or
what
what i know could happen
it's just
it's just what it is
and um
you know
being that i came from a
a good family nobody really gets me
out here but i have a good heart you
know i don't
i don't hurt anybody out here but myself
and it's not intentionally it's just
what happens
out here um
you know
i learned how to make money by
stealing and robbing people and
caught three strikes like that
and um
you know i lost
i lost myself out here and
every time i try to get sober and
and and
with with uh jennifer because they they
call me iris out here iris the virus
um
there's still a part of me that
you know when i'm sober i'm
uncomfortable in my
but when i'm out here
and i'm i'm under some kind of influence
it feels like that's who i am
and um
it's not the way that society wants me
to be but it is it's just how it is
i can stay sober for a year or two and
then
one day i'm just back
and it's all over again
you know
it's all over i just relapsed two weeks
ago
i got a warrant right now
so
and it's normal
you know it's the normal thing for me
and it's crazy
um
you know
i couldn't tell you why i have want my
teeth or
why i've never been stabbed or shot
other than i must have angels on my
on my shoulders because
i have done some of the most awfulest
things out here and some of the most
awfulest things have happened to me
um
and i've always just
it's always just been
you know nothing really i i don't know i
shouldn't say nothing really bad i guess
people would say rapes are really bad
but
compared to some of the other women i've
seen out here
i just feel so blessed i still have my
sanity i still have my uh
my heart
you know i'm
i'm disease free um
but
i have this side of me that just
is a criminal
a real criminal
without a thought and um that's the
scary part
you know because the streets just made
me somebody who
i wasn't born to be
you know
um
i wasn't born to be like this
would i change it no
i like me
i like me i like uh
i just um i couldn't ever see me being
any other way
but i um you know i transformed i i just
say i would just say i just i
transformed i have eight brothers and
sisters
you know i have um
chp
uh brothers and
i have some military family and
you know uh i'm the only one i'm the
only one that's been to prison i'm the
only one that's on drugs
and i'm the only one that they call when
something goes wrong too
because they know i'm gonna get it done
and um
you know i i
this is just uh um
all i wish is that somebody could
understand that
it's really not a choice
you know it's it's it's a
it's a disease
there's a disease
whether it's a disease of addiction or
disease of the lifestyle
there's something that calls me out here
every time
it doesn't matter
i could be sitting at home with
my family
watching tv in the nice house with a
nice car with a great job
and then here i come
right back
for no reason
and i pay the consequence every time by
myself
so
anything else
you feel like you belong here
i mean like the streets are
more comfortable more you than
a better life
uh
i feel like
i belong here a lot more than i do when
i'm
on the so-called normal side and there's
no reason for that other than my
self-esteem
because i'm super intelligent
i can land a job in a minute
um
but i feel like on my forehead it says
criminal crackhead prostitute
i just feel like that
i feel like it's it's in my it's
embedded in me somewhere you know
especially when they run my record i
look like crap on paper
you know and it's really hard to
make friendships with normies who've
never experienced what i've experienced
because then it's always like oh
that happened to you it's not a sad
story
it's just a story
and it just made me stronger everything
that happened to me has just made me
stronger
it doesn't define me
or make me weak it just made me a
survivor
and it gave me a lot of um
insight
because i know that
my story one day
sometimes still does now
can help somebody else
you know i see young girls out here
young girls like me i didn't even know
what crack cocaine was when i was
smoking
i had no idea i thought there was one
drug in the whole world i thought it was
heroin
and that was what i saw in a movie i was
that naive
um but i see young girls out here and i
i see them getting you know
pimped out or whatever and i
and i try to just tell them in another
way there's just another way
you know um
because i wish somebody would have told
me
i wish somebody would have helped me i
wish just one person would have cared
and nobody cared
nobody cared
i was a 16 year old
a little skinny naive little white girl
in the pits of south central and nobody
cared
nobody
so if that's my purpose to be out here
and be the one person that does care
then so be it
was it sexual abuse that you went
through as a kid
a big factor in where you're at today
i definitely think that the sexual abuse
made me very promiscuous which made me
um
have a sexual appetite
that
made
sex on the streets
enjoyable
you know um the drugs go with that
absolutely
absolutely but
like
my story would be more like
i tried the prostitution thing for a
very small time when i was made to
i'm i'm more sexual just because i was
loaded and i just wanted to do it
and it's such a blessing because i mean
70 of my friends have hiv
you know how i didn't get it
i just wasn't in the circle of my
friends that's it i was i always wanted
people to think i wasn't doing it so i
was very
discreet
you know if you if you ever ask somebody
hey does she does she prostitute nah
they'd never say yes
but i did a whole lot
and i was just very discreet condoms
didn't use them i don't know how i'm
telling you i'm blessed
i'm blessed
and blessed
what's been your lowest point
my lowest point would be um
probably 2017 when i lost my uh
when they came and took my kids
and my partner at the time had been
clean for 10 years and he went out right
behind me
and i was just on a suicide mission i
didn't care
i didn't care about anything
and i didn't see any way to get my son
back um
and i didn't get him back
that was uh
i just lost him last december
and that was my lowest point
because um
when i had him
he's seven but when i had him um
nobody even knew i was pregnant
i was pregnant for nine months
and nobody in my life paid any attention
to me that they never even noticed i had
a nine-month belly on me
nobody
nobody i had them alone in a hospital
with nurses
drug free because i had stopped using
nobody noticed that part either
and um
you know i just didn't i didn't have the
tools to stay clean i stayed clean for
the first three years of his life and
then
i got loaded and
you know once i'm out there i can't i
i'm not going to sit here and pretend i
can take care of kids because i can't i
don't do that i don't bring my kids out
here my kids have never seen me loaded
you know and i thought i was doing the
best thing but i wasn't because i have a
26 year old right now who can't stand me
because i was never around
you know but i thought i was doing the
best thing i could you know
i just didn't want him down here
but um yeah my lowest point was
definitely but i lost my my uh
my little boy
because i i never thought i was um
i always thought i was a little bit
stronger than that i always thought that
um
that i'd be able to do that for him
and that was just the one thing i
couldn't do
because um
i was clean two years i was
30 days getting full custody and i
relapsed
30 days
it's crazy right
yeah
thanks
what do you think most people don't
understand
about
drugs and addiction in the streets and
all that i think that everybody thinks
it's a choice
and um
it might be a choice when you're in
it but i'm telling you
that it just sneaks on you
there's no there's nothing in my brain
that says i want to
get up one day and leave my apartment
and lose my job and lose my car and walk
out on my boyfriend and leave my kids
and never show up again
there's nothing about me that says it
but it happens every time
every time
and i'm a runner because i can't face
anybody
i'll show you my phone right now they're
all calling
i've never got clean any other way but
going to jail
the same cell was sitting at 18 is the
same when i sit at 42.
you know what they don't understand is
that
i can't even say
you don't stop until you want to because
i want to
i don't know
i don't know if there's a cure i don't
know if it's just for some people or if
it's not i don't know because i've tried
everything
i've tried everything
and it always leads back to the same
place
and so at some point you kind of just go
dang what am i trying for
you know
but
what are you afraid of at this point in
your life
spend the rest of my life in prison
that's it
because i'm on my way
i have an open case right now
and i have a 15-year joint suspension if
i don't finish this program and i'm
i've been running for two weeks again
so
that's not where i'm supposed to die at
in prison
but
you know
if it happens it happens
i know i'll be in there alone
because i messed up out here so bad you
know
my grandmother
nobody even answers my calls anymore
let alone write a letter so
yeah
how much love did you feel as a child
you said your dad was a
aryan and my dad um i was an alcoholic
my dad was
my dad went to prison so
i got a good dad but my parents were
young um
my grandparents were functioning middle
class alcoholics
but they didn't
i didn't feel any love
um
they bought me everything i never wanted
for anything
but
the hugs and the i love yous absolutely
not
uh
i got a b-plus in school it was like why
didn't you get an a
i did the ballet and the tap and the
saxophone and the jazz and
it was always like you turned wrong you
did this you know
i didn't feel i didn't feel ever like i
was ever good enough to this day
i never feel like my best is good enough
and love no
absolutely not you know my grandpa was
probably the only one i felt loved me
and he died of cirrhosis of the liver
when i was 14.
so i really didn't want to be there
after that
you know
and dad you know my my outfit doesn't
fall far from the tree
my dad was snorted coke and
been a prison for robbery like me
you know but we never saw it either he's
an aryan and his beliefs are definitely
not mine because my children are mixed
but
you know
it's just uh
childhood was
financially fun i guess
but
like i love you it's absolutely not my
mom saw me uh
my mom died when i was 20.
she was 37
and i was in jail
and went to the first time she ever came
to visit and she knocked on the window
before she left and she was like i love
you
and i was like
i love you weird like oh whatever
i didn't know it was the last time i was
going to see her
she never said that before
i didn't know i didn't know what to say
if i would have only known right
what's your biggest regret
my biggest regret
there's so many
my biggest regret would probably be
leaving my children behind
every time
every time i left him behind um
or maybe always picking men over me
i always put a man before myself
and they were never worthy
ever
um
i didn't even realize that until it was
brought to my attention like last year
but i always put a relationship or
somebody else in front of me
and then i'm the one that's
without
their kids or without their freedom or
that's my story yeah
i always put somebody first i'm so loyal
i'm loyal to a fault
i am loyal to
tom dick and harry and
they don't even know my name it's awful
i have been loyal to the wrong people i
have been loyal to
people who have beat me and
set me up and just
sold me just
things just
i sit amongst people who have
really really dogged me out
and i'm just such a forgiving person
that
or i think i'm just an adult now because
i'll tell them like remember when you
did this
but
who does that why would you want to be
in the company of somebody who hurt you
especially when you were a young girl
you know
i always say they got old and i got
grown
iris what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
the most important lesson
that everything passes
nothing's permanent
everything's temporary
whether it's good or bad
it's gonna pass
so don't get comfortable
don't get comfortable
just take it for what it is and enjoy it
or let it go
but everything passes
thank god
all right iris thank you so much for
sharing yourself you're so welcome
thank you very much you're so very
welcome
you